[Music]
hello thank you very much I am from
Scotland I was born in England but do
consider myself fully Scottish because
my mom's an alcoholic in my dad's
clinically obese so just kind of works
it also makes me half American so it's
nice to be home I know I like it I've
moved out a year ago and my mom's
biggest fear when I moved out was that I
was gonna become a drug addict which was
very naive of her because I was a drug
addict when I lived with her I was just
much better at hiding it now when I say
drug addict I don't do drugs
I do drug I do one drug I do a drug I'm
willing to pay about 50% of people in
this room would have tried at one point
or another I track a lot of people
everyone do agree how it should be fully
legal everywhere by now because it's got
no real health ramifications math my
wife's taste of skinny no more so my
weight I do smoke weed I'm not trying to
make it seem cool it does that itself I
do it because I trust it okay I don't do
any other drugs because all other drugs
can kill you okay even alcohol can kill
you I mean obviously you still drink
alcohol because otherwise I winter for
personality so but if you go to a party
with somebody overdoses now alcohol
that's a very serious moment that's
Daniel K come quick
Steve's overdosed alcohol how does he
look oh it's awful he's on the floor
he's barely breathing he's in the pool
of his own vomit we're gonna have to get
the hospital and we're gonna have to get
stomach pumped as opposed to Daniel dan
come quick Steve's overdose of marijuana
how does he look comfortable he's
watching Shrek do we have any Pringle
I am let's find the stoners in the crowd
there I still smoked weed when a little
with my parents
Ivy's had to be subtle about it I didn't
want them to find out it's the best time
I could ever choose to get high was
whenever I was babysitting my younger
brothers now okay
before we get judgmental one important
bit of information that you need to
remember is that I don't love them said
of the Meijer I wasn't doing around them
right all they knew was that I was going
outside for 10 minutes and then coming
back and funner and they loved it they'd
be like can we got a bedtime story be
like yeah you can get better
how about we build a fort first we
really enjoy America when I'm here you
guys have negative stereotypes which you
don't like all Americans are stupid all
Americans are stupid not true absolutely
not true all Americans are fat all
Americans are fat not true it's just
when you guys are fight it's impressive
a country that believes that obesity is
a disease but homosexuality is a choice
okay so if your fire don't worry about
it that's not your fault you were
probably born that way but if you're gay
must be something you ate was it penis
[Applause]
be gay isn't the choice if being gay was
a choice there wouldn't be one straight
man left on this planet do you think if
I could make myself gay I wouldn't do it
right now and make my life ten times
easier do you know how much money I'd
save being gay is a choice it's not a
very fair one okay so you got two
options you can either spend the rest of
your life pursuing women and which kiss
is gonna take you anywhere from one in
six weeks trying to seduce woo and charm
woman into bed through veiling method of
Lies to cease and untruths it's gonna
cost you a lot of time money in sani but
eventually she'll concede and you'll
make love together and be this beautiful
moment then you spend more and more time
together following more and more in love
but while you're spending this time
together what she's secretly doing is
she's put blinders on the side of your
face so you can't see there has to be
like her past you friends family fun
ambition memories dreams and before you
know it you're 45 control to your mind
with two kids and all your dreams are
dead or or you can hang it with your
best friend all day and get [ __ ]
what a difficult choice I'm not gay
though I don't like hummus so that's
that's why they call them homosexuals
that's thanks don't laugh at that that's
shameful yeah thing is I belong to the
generation that uses the term gay as an
insult I've been guilty over myself and
the reason it's wrong is because it
makes no sense
what's insulting about that statement
like if I was walking down the street
and a man yelled out to me yell okay I'd
be like really I just woke up I just
threw this whole a dollar game I think
you might be the homosexual because you
sir are flirting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]